♪♪
Paddle out again?
Race you to the next one.
♪♪
Woo!
I love Surfside.
It's a little strange.
My dad says you're
never too old to use
your imagination.
You're also never too
young to
use your brain.
Look!
This coin is AU-79.
Also known as gold!
The cursed treasure!
I don't know about cursed
but this is
definitely treasure.
♪♪
There's something going on
in Surfside.
But you might be able to
get to the bottom of it.
Peligro.
What's that mean?
Danger.
Uhh...
Salutations
Are you an actual ghost?
My mates call me Remy.
Is that...
Definitely not a buoy.
So we got a pirate ghost...
cursed treasure...
and a booby trapped room.
That's not a sentence
you hear everyday.
If we don't solve
the mystery....
ancient evil
will be unleashed.
Also a sentence you
don't hear everyday.
♪♪
How does it all connect?
It's a total mystery.
No way.
Jade has these new friends.
We're really different.
But no one get's me
like Sam does.
You need to think
outside the box.
And over time you'll come
to appreciate that.
It's good to be a
little strange.
I'm strange.
Me too dude.
I'll say.
♪♪